ça tourne à satan lahoud je suis chez
moi personne va dans cette pièce à part
moi ok je suis excité là je vous
préviens je suis hyper excité j'ai hâte
de tourner c'est pas comme les activités
manuelles ou j'appréhende la
j'appréhende rien du tout là c'est vous
qui appréhendaient écoutez c'est la
première vidéo que je tourne à part le
serai d'horreur depuis la fin de mes
vacances et j'ai mélangé plusieurs trucs
que j'avais envie de faire dans ma tête
et ça donnait le concept d'aujourd'hui
le premier truc que j'avais en tête
c'est que je suis allé à la fnac
j'adore ce magasin d'ailleurs il ya
aussi appris comment est un moment je
passe devant un présentoir et qu'est-ce
qui assure ce présentoir des cahiers de
vacances vous souvenez de ça deux camps
de vacances j'avais oublié cet objet et
[ __ ] pourtant qu'est-ce que j'en ai
fait enfin qu'est ce que ma mère m'a
obligé à en faire évidemment j'aurais
préféré jouer à britten dogs bref j'en
ai acheté je suis un [ __ ] de came fait
comme si tout était normal dans ce que
je dis j'en ai acheté un niveau regardez
bien de la sixième à la cinquième
d'accord j'ai deux fois l'âge des gens
qui sont en 6e et vous savez quoi
j'avais fo a plein de questions je
dirais pas la plupart des questions mais
je dirais une sur deux sur trois ce qui
a eu pour effet de détruire
littéralement mon ego c'est donc ça le
premier truc que j'avais en tête c'est
mais attend les cahiers de vacances pour
les 6e 5e un adulte il n'a pas 100 % de
bonnes réponses du tout et cette
anecdote m'amuse et la deuxième chose
c'est que ça fait un moment qu'on n'a
pas fait un petit truc ensemble sur
cette chaîne youtube comme ianoukovitch
qui traîne ne pouvait pas faire un
tournage ensemble ils rêvent du coup on
va faire un tournage ensemble à distance
sur mon discorde se trouvent quatre
groupes de dix élèves toutes tranches
d'âge
je crois que ça va de 14 ans à trente
deux ans auquel sont tous mélangés
aujourd'hui on va jouer à un jeu j'avais
enfin jean teulé cette phrase tu es
devant sow et je me suis fait chier
dessus ils vont être des élèves et je
vais poser des questions qui se trouvent
dans ce cahier de vacances qcm en plus
assez simple tu sais moi d'accord
restez vous allez voir vous allez avoir
faut à la plupart des questions plupart
jeunes s'étaient enflammés mais pas mal
quand même
ils écriront la réponse sur une feuille
qu'ils retourneront tout ce confort ça
dégage le gagnant reste pour la finale
et le gagnant la finale remporte un truc
je ne suis pas penché sur cette partie
là est-ce que tout est clair pour vous
qu'un vidéo blizzard projets en vue de
cette vidéo blizzard
bref aujourd'hui notre première classe
pourquoi personne ne masque et et mettez
tous vos matches vous prenez quoi chez
le professeur y en a quand même il ya un
gros fail okami sont basses conne mais
au cas où
bon comment allez vous super ça fait
plaisir de vous voir vous est passé de
bonnes vacances
vous avez tous une feuille et un stylo
je sais pas ouais c'est bon ok il ya
quatre classes de dix élèves comme vous
qui m'attend vous êtes les 6e b il y
aura un gros gagnants dans chaque classe
ensuite les grands gagnants
s'affronteront est le grand gagnant des
grand gagnant remportera un truc que
j'ai prévu parce que je travaille mes
vidéos t'inquiète vous montrez vos
réponses et tous ceux qui ont la bonne
réponse reste est ce qu'on la mauvaise
réponse
ça dégage directement
est-ce que vous êtes prêts oui au début
c'est simple farage du sun en vrai c'est
tout un simple faiseur de foi y en a qui
vont se tromper français voilà donc
comment écrit-on le verbe plongé à la
troisième personne du singulier de
l'indicatif pas c'est simple c'est pour
les 6e je rappelle c'est pour les
sixièmes à plonge apl ong à bp l ong ea
s'est plongée ge a été ça vous rappelle
des souvenirs ou pas envie de chialer
je voulais je vous laisse un petit
instant écrivait quand tout le monde est
bon attendez à damien carter attendez
attendez livre un son carnet en fait
direct
alors damien oui bonjour vous êtes en
retard ouais c'est parce que j'habite
troupes un peu plus loin c'est peut-être
pour ça damien thatcher dit even donc
traitée par d'honnêtes inquiète mais
sans le tee shirts à sauter un bon est
ce que vous êtes paix et 1 2 3 tout le
monde retourne son petit papier y en a
il y en a il y en a forcément qui dégage
je suis abattu mais non il y en a deux
ils savent la qui sont dans la merde
bien d'ailleurs ils savent
inès et damien vous avez tout donné mais
c'est terminé pas au goût d'aventuré on
admire sativa locker ferron qui vient
d'arriver le passage des plus courts de
l'histoire
ok deuxième question maintenant les
choses vont s'accélérer là c'était la
mise en bouche voilà je vous laisse du
temps maintenant je vous laisse et 10
secondes et on en parle plus oula quelle
est la fonction du groupe nominal
soulignait je ne me souviens plus de cet
exercice de cet exercice étant la partie
souligné de la phrase à ses os b coi
c'est cod hop là dix secondes tim
tierney qui firent la fin je retire rien
du tout c'est comme ceux ci c'est bon on
monte tout sauvage et j'ai paniqué
messieurs dames
la bonne réponse était la paix l'escaut
il est à toi tu as ton brevet alors
remettez vos papiers je ne sais même pas
qu'il ya eu faute aux catastrophes
albacete show your et rennes ce chao
samantha c'est ciao
mais j'ai mis ces eaux des bahamas la
coi belle tentative
belle tentative de corruption nouvelle
question mat bien comme les maths non
comme en écriture en toutes lettres le
nombre 80 réponse à 80 tout collé
réponse b 80 avec un tiret répond c'est
80 avec un tiret et un s à la fin
messieurs dames vos réponses dans des
gros doutes ouf je vous ai quelque chose
j'aurais fou c'est bel et bien la
réponse c'est oui la page 20 prend 1 s
incroyable incroyable on en apprend des
choses et parfois on dit si fille 84 il
n'y a pas de s
toi tu est à deux doigts d'un supporter
les gens moins bon que toi non je me
tourne là je me sens julien sacha vous
êtes en finale il ya une pression dans
cette version d'un coup c'est incroyable
le métal le plus intéressant pour
fabriquer des pièces d'avions et à
l'acier b le cuivre c'est le titane
c'est là non c'est pas non
target pas cadré une feuille c'est bon
oh mon dieu non c'est le sait le c'est
le pire scénario
c'était le titane tu me connais pas en
avion
attendez je vais juste a pu leur être
voir ce qui se passe ici à égalité j'ai
pas prévu que si je vais leur annoncer
la terrible nouvelle
messieurs dames la production a tranché
dans les 6e b il n'y a pas de gagnant à
il fallait tenir le marathon effet en
fait faut aller au bout quoi faut qu on
est elle si j'aurai une battle royal
voilà c'est un battle royale mais là
c'est comme si à la fin tu vois la zone
elle se rétrécit on est morts tous les
deux le voilà c'est ça exactement et
demeure dans la zone ces bouilles triste
à la fois mais j'ai passé un très bon
moment avec vous et moi et je vais vous
dire un truc moi j'allais dire le cuivre
allait bientôt l'habiller petit débrief
là entre entre deux classes là c'est les
5 minutes là entre deux cours ça fait
trop du bien de voir autant de gens il
parlait autant de gens d'un coup voir
des visages des sourires des trucs s'est
fait plaisir de ouf
ok le groupe 2 comment allez-vous bien
très bien
alors qui a fait des cahiers de vacances
quand il était plus jeune moi j'aimerais
tellement plein tout le monde sent là la
mère forcée mais j'ai toujours lutté
ah ouais t'as jamais cédé l'arrêt et ben
brik je vais dire un truc tu vas t'en
mordre les doigts aujourd'hui alors
qu'elles n'ont vous faut-il ajouter à 24
72 pour obtenir 51 réponse à 26 28
réponse b 25-28 réponse c'est 27,28 et
montrez moi vos réponses on ya tous ces
incroyables attendait l messieurs dames
c'est incroyable on est tout de suite en
finale là que toi c'est une écurie
la réponse était bel et bien 26,28 c'est
incroyable ce qui se passe kourichi cas
ce qu'on peut dire qu il ya des lianes 1
c'est drôle juste parce qu'il ya le mot
bonbons j'adore nadia un paquet de 109
bombes ont tué voudrais partager
équitablement entre 12 copine combien
chacune des filles aura-t-elle de
bonbons réponse à 9
réponse b 6 réponse ces huit ya combien
de la base
fallait il fallait écouter 109 109
bonbons de base alors la réponse donc si
vous avez 10 9
et effectivement ccc paa est assez
complète jean-pierre serait pas de
gagnant dans les quatrièmes des on a
créé un groupe pour réviser tout à
l'heure on a tout fait et ça ça va
vraiment pas porté ses fruits donc en
tout cas merci à vous merci a pris du
temps pour moi ça m'a fait super courage
pour la reprise ciao les amis un gros
bisou messieurs dames on n'a toujours
pas de gagner mais ça soufflera pas de
gagnant à la fois il fait beau un escroc
malin c'est l'heure d'accueillir les
cinquièmes c'est pas mal va mal les
petites classes bien joué à goyave je
crois qu'on est obligé d'enlever le font
parce que sinon le papier ça soit en a
il a pas levé la main pour parler ça
c'est attention
oui oui touba ce qu'est une femme
derrière vous oui alors je vous présente
pas la nive tout à fait c'est mélanie
vous pouvez la saluer jamais la nuit
tombée lundi
voilà tout ce monde est prêt on est prêt
c'est parti on traite toutes les chaînes
alimentaires répond ça débute par un
animal réponse b débutent par un végétal
réponse et débute par de la matière
minérale
j'ai déjà perdu comment je fais ce matin
des foetus marie vous répéter la
question s'il vous plaît alors atelier à
tous de nakata pas levé la main était
interdit de parler pendant une minute
pierre oui moi j'aimerai savoir on
marque le
la lettre on marque tout la réponse est
ce que ça peut être une question des
changements dans sa compagne est ce que
la question à choix multiples non mais
laissez moi j'ai pas ces questions là ça
non là y'en a qu'une et messieurs dames
il s'agit effectivement de la réponse b
puisque c'est tout les choses à long
terme l'état par un végétal
on aime on compte les cinquièmes peu
anglais marie quoi est-ce que je peux
échanger avec eux pierre puisqu'il n'a
même pas l'anglais moi j'aime bien en
anglais je peux les lieux je suis
délégué donc techniquement et là il est
vraiment délicate aux habitants basse tu
l'emmènes chez le cpe et du coup elle
elle retire ses avocats marie pendant
une minute ya plus de ouakam de moi
alors c'est terrible anglais laquelle de
ces phrases exprime une action passée
réponse à chiffa ns et celui réponse b
chez found the solution réponse et she
will find the solution
monsieur vous pouvez l'écrire au tableau
si vous poussez absolument hors de
question mélanie c'est mort
j'ai une question marie elle n'avait pas
le droit de parler monsieur vélo non non
non mais je t'ai pas dit mais marie tu
te muter tu veux dire c'est au toac a
maintenant c'est d'homme ça montrez moi
vos feuilles marie petit à petit jouet
marie c'est pas possible
messieurs dames sachez que c'était la
réponse b accorde ce participes passés
vos cousines ont mangé toutes les
cerises réponse à manger et réponse b
manger et es réponse et manger et s
les réponses touba ce que vraiment il
est énorme
aussi sachez que c'était la réponse à
manger et il reste donc que dans lequel
pierre on est d'accord monsieur wyser
car je peux juste vous dire une
anecdotes drôles puisqu'on a le temps
non ok question ce fait comme en
écriture
nos amis sont partis hier réponse à
partir
réponse b partie i s réponse c'est parti
es comme ans écrivent nos amis
excellente question malka évidemment nos
amis ies
la réponse c'est marrant
réponse c'est bien joué à vous les êtres
vivants du sol réponse à des composent
la matière minérale en matière organique
réponse b décompose la matière organique
en matière minérale réponse et
n'agissent pas sur les matières
biodégradables
on a regagné et il s'appelle la le cas
là on a gagné je suis vu c'était pas
arrivé eh bien écoutez les 5mg c'est ce
fut une vraie partie de plaisir
marie tu m'auras bien fait rire élèves
turbulents bombay l'année - vous
remercie pour votre participation mais
ça a pris du temps pour moi dans lequel
on se retrouve après pour la finale et
je vais tout simplement rejoindre les
troisièmes un hello hello fait déjà
trois heures qu'on est en vocal on
t'attend à vous êtes devenu meilleur
pote de noël bizarre on est le meilleur
vous avez vu des petits papiers team 14
mai à doha doit rester dans mon rôle de
prof et grimés j'avais trouvé une
question qui était pas mal pourquoi vous
je vous cache pas je vous je vous je
vais vouloir peut vous marchese alors on
peut dire que 74 mille trois cent
soixante cinq secondes
vale réponse à 20 heures 38 minutes et
25 secondes
je pousse b 19 heures 34 minutes et 24
secondes
réponse et 20 heures 39 minutes et 25
messieurs doivent retourner vos feuilles
s'il vous plaît il ya des gens qui m'ont
sauté rien et je m'accepte alors
messieurs dames la bonne réponse et
cette question elle était pas sans elle
n'était pas simple elle en a surpris
plus d'un la bonne réponse était la
réponse c'est avec 20h39
evans est bien d'accord vous avez tous
eu la réflexion genre ouais là l acl
sont proches donc c'est l'une des deux
mondes non mais celui d'hier dans une
heure il ya 3600 secondes de ça et j'ai
mis tu m'as perdu à part aller les pipes
facile à j'ai vu depuis longtemps bordel
un parallélépipède rectangle à pour
mesure 3,5 cm 2 4 cm et 3 cm sous volume
et deux réponses à 25,2 centimètres
cubes
réponse b 25,2 cm² réponse et 25,4 cm
cube
j'attends que le hasard met encore
messieurs dames c'était effectivement
25,2 centimètres cubes à savoir la
réponse à lequel des trois mots suivants
est anglais réponse à environnement ça
s'écrit comme environnement en français
réponse b environnement comme en
français mais hier un seul n comme
noémie et réponses et environnement s'il
vous plaît je vois vos réponses
maintenant alors c'est bel et bien la
réponse c est assez le gel je suis
désolé mais le carnet il ne reste que 3
chloé john et mathieu alors les levures
ça commence très mal répond ça mange la
farine pour grossir réponse b utilise la
farine et produisent du gaz
réponse c utilise la farine et
produisent du sucre
montrez moi vos réponses s'il vous plaît
aux ja le japon petit frère valentin du
monde salue valentin et tu peux fermer
la porte
ça c'est une manière polie de dire
dégage fait haute et c'était la réponse
b utilise la farine et produisent du gaz
c'est la finale entre cloud et mathieu à
mon dieu un volume de 16 57 mètres cubes
correspond à réponse à 16000 570 litres
réponse b 165,7 litres réponse et 165
mille sept cents litre atteint là il ya
trop annoncé le doute sur sa bonté moi
vos réponses chloé et matthieu haut
c'est spectaculaire ce qui se passe il
s'agit
effectivement de 16500 70 s et la
réponse a cloué dans ce final incroyable
je vous fais des bisous merci tout le
monde merci les troisièmes à la team 4
merci beaucoup
une quatre ans commentaires désabusés
vous on a une finale je suis content et
pour cette occasion on va résoudre des
problèmes de cm2 c'est faux cette fois
c'est trop chiant et je vais acheter
jusqu'à 120 chiens je vais être honnête
avec vous au moment où on se parle je
sais toujours pas ce que le gagnant
gagne mais il va gagner un truc tu
m'avais monk et marca chloé ça va mais
sympa bien messieurs dames c'est
exactement le même jeu sauf qu'il ya que
vous deux opus finir vite du coup ça
peut se finir très vite ou alors ça peut
être très long et très chiant triplé
très vite mais en ma faveur
nouvelle question la vitesse de
propagation de la lumière et à la même
que celle du sommet plus petite que
celle du son c'est beaucoup plus élevée
que celle du son est fait car midi vos
réponses et non c'est bien sa réponse
est beaucoup plus élevée que celle du
son vous avez vu qu'il n'ya plus le
camarade il ya plus d'ambiance ans est
très serré vénale pour transmettre une
information on utilise exclusivement un
signal lumineux exclusivement un signal
sonore
là où l'autre voire les deux à la fois
y'a pas le contexte non
quelle surprise quelle surprise
messieurs dames ce qui se passe c'est
spectaculaire pour transmettre une
information on utilise
c'est la réponse est là ou l'autre voire
les deux à l'apport de la recrue
hivernale cas à yahia il va devoir
annoncer la dure nouvelle au 5e c il y
pense et moi je suis contente pour les
copains malka je suis désolé moi aussi
quand j'ai lu la question le manque de
contexte m'a fait me dire boîte mais
qu'est ce c'est quoi ce délire noël
c'est ça et en fait effectivement
pourtant on se met une info je te parle
ou alors je te montre pire explications
mais voilà tu a saisi les débats merci
dale carr est ce que je peux dire juste
un tout petit mot mais bien sûr on
oratoire je finis bientôt mes études et
c'était juste pour vous dire que je suis
également streamer sur twitch alors si
vous voulez m'apporter un peu de soutien
ce n'est qu'à 17 si vous voulez faire un
petit coucou si vous voulez aller dire
dans le chat que les troisièmes à son
meilleur il était pas clamé robben ont
alors saisi la balle au bond à bisous
dans le cas merci mon dieu merci
alors que là on a un problème qu'est ce
que c'est je sais pas c'est quoi le
cadeau grave
donc j'ai une dernière question à ton
avis où est située cette île je ne sais
pas je vais dire un truc copie pareil
c'est la corse fixé un cahier de
vacances français et ben écoute moi bien
clouer j'en sais foutrement rien mais en
tout cas tu viens de gagner des vacances
en corse débat vrai je te jure je suis
toujours pouvoir le timing quand c'est
possible et c'est pascal co vite mais je
t'offre des vacances en corse clos mais
c'est trop bien mais merci beh je t'en
prie je prends weier que j'allais avoir
un truc aussi où des jeunes sélectionnés
merci moi je sais pas ça m'a inspiré
j'ai vu ni je me suis dit mais on a
envie d'y retourner sur une île l'un
d'eux car elles ont su jamais là encore
sans plus et ben trop bien une semaine
avec deux potes à toi tranquille tu
choisiras la maison tu veux aller
toutous et moi juge de paix ben merci
attends tu as gagné il fallait faire
gagner un truc que tu peux annoncer la
nouvelle au troisième à ils vont être
contents les troisièmes a encore bravo
c'était vraiment ça partait à ma mère si
on revient 10 ou chloé hannah chao merci
beaucoup
à bientôt
[Musique]
eh ben les amis c'était trop bien
j'espère que c'était aussi bien pour
vous pour moi mais alors moins qu'elle
kiffe
ça fait trop plaisir de voir certains
d'entre vous parler avec eux de les
vannes et de rires de c'était vraiment
un trop bon moment donc voilà j'ai kiffé
de malades et ne sous-estimez jamais les
cahiers de la course pour 6e même si
vous avez deux ou trois voilages j'ai
trop kiffé ya pas mal de trucs cool
prévu en vidéo cette année j'espère
juste que la crise sanitaire va vite se
terminer a comme ça on pourra refaire
des tournages un peu plus cool mais bon
attendent enfin les petits concept comme
c'est un peu drôle et voilà j'espère que
ça vous a plus vraiment moi j'ai
vraiment pris mon pied je suis heureux
merci à tous prenez soin de vous courage
pour la rentrée même si c'était y'a
écran vient de pertinence et outreau a
très vite
[Musique]